hi everyone it's Jerry I'm going to
challenge Chad GPT to a game of chess
this is open AI chatbot you can have a
conversation with it basically has all
the answers to the world's problems
with some disclaimers
okay
I challenge you to a game of chess
see what we got oh all right the
challenge has been accepted
I don't have a physical presence to move
the pieces on a physical board but I can
definitely play a game of chess with you
we can use algebraic notation to make
the moves and communicate the state of
the game I'll make the first move wow I
was actually prepared to
use a different type of
notation
to maybe
avoid possible issues but if you say
algebraic notation
let's see if we could
get a good game going
okay great first move
my reply is
let's go with the Sicilian Defense
excellent I'm playing the Sicilian
Defense here's the updated board whole
very thorough
all right I should put that move on by
the way all right E4 C5 now I'll make my
second move Knight F3 while this is
Flowing very nicely
your turn
oh
okay
my second move is
D6
let's put it on first
and see what we get
great here's the updated board I'm
liking it this is perfect all right I
thought I was gonna have to be doing a
lot of copying and pasting
got the little move list along the way
that's beautiful now I'll make my third
move d4
okay you're going into an open Sicilian
I see
okay
my third move is
c x D4 now hopefully the notation is not
going to mess up the chap out c x D4
should be
sufficient
C takes D or C takes D4 let's see what
we get
good move here's the updated board now
I'll make my fourth move Knight takes D4
okay all right uh how good is this thing
gonna play am I gonna get beat
that'd be pretty bad
all right let's go with Knight F6 I like
this one put a little pressure on the
pawn
see if you
know what to do
okay
my fourth probably don't have to type
this but whatever
my fourth move is Knight F6 let's make
sure I get the notation right there we
go
ooh complimenting me now
I made a good move
now I'll make my fifth move Knight C6
that is a perfect move so far so book
chat GPT playing like a machine
like the world's top engine stockfish so
far okay Knight C3
okay my fifth
move is
we're gonna go with the Sicilian nidorf
let's see if it knows that that's what
we're applying
okay my fifth move is
A6
here's the updated board man this is
this is working perfect so far
I'll make my sixth move Bishop E2 okay
I'm gonna be curious once we get out of
book
this has all been seen many times before
that's when
that's that's what I'm most curious
about I guess okay Bishop E2
should I say great move
why not great move
my sixth
if I could type
sixth move is
we're gonna scare the night boom
E5
okay
so this Knight normally goes to B3
now I'll make my seventh move Knight B3
man
gotta get this bot out of book
Okay so
good move
my seventh move is okay now so I'm not
used to typing and playing so this is
different I have to actually think and
play chess
make good moves here so
I have just weakened my D5 Square
so I need to take care of her that
and let's develop and defend the whole
on D5 so we're gonna go with Bishop e
six
all right nice move here's the updated
board beautiful
now I'll make my eighth move castles
okay
flawless
now
I'm done complimenting the the bot okay
my eighth
g h
my eighth move is okay I gotta think now
okay this guy normally goes here
to secure this guy if there's ever the
capture I'm recapturing with the Knight
and there you go I'm watching over the
most
uh the the weakest Square in my Camp so
let's
let's go with this one oh this it could
get a little
um okay so the notation for this one is
a little bit unique than the other ones
that I've put in so far this one is
night
I have to clarify which Knight
B
D seven
okay hopefully that registers
we're gonna find out
uh oh okay cool it's not saying it
doesn't understand
let's see Knight bd7 now make my ninth
move F4
wow okay so ready to
F4 is a threat
I have to watch out for this
because I don't want to have to meet
or excuse me F5 is a threat I don't want
to have to meet this move with Bishop
takes Knight because this is this is
White's worst minor piece
so I need to be in a spot to
let's say meet F5 with Bishop C4 so I'm
going to develop my queen
to C7 so I want to have this Square in
the event of F5
all right
so
okay my move my ninth
move is
Queen C seven
what do you got
flawless
now make my 10th move King H1 oh
well
um I might be uh sweating a little bit
here so King H1 that's that's like a
high class waiting move what's what's
going on here I'm I'm a little bit
concerned that there might be a pawn
storm
with the push Bishop here and then this
guy may be being launched
and I may have to do something with my
knight soon
all right I think either way this is a
good follow-up
Bishop to E7
let me make sure I want to do that
yeah I think that that's cool where else
is he gonna go I don't want to make any
pawn moves
yeah okay Bishop we're gonna go Bishop
B7
my
10th
move
is Bishop E7
okay
good move here's the updated board
beautiful
I could probably say to it you don't
need to
tell me the updated board just give me
your moves but I'll let it I'll let it
run like this that's okay Queenie one
man
all right
so
getting a little nervous this Queen's
coming over here is going to be pressure
on that pawn
all right we're we're still in theory I
imagine
this has all been seen before
all right
my
11th move is
hmm what do I want to play here I don't
know if I want a castle just yet
I have to make a decision I'm gonna I
guess I'll Castle yeah let's Castle
yeah because maybe
maybe after Castle's Queen G3
I could play King h8 because after this
Castle Queen G3
there may be then the threat to play F5
and then Bishop H6 taking advantage of
the pinch Pawn
so
castles Queen G3 I could play here right
away King in the corner just like white
did and I'm out of any pin on the G file
okay
so
we're gonna Castle
all right
zero
Dash zero
okay
updated board a good choice
we're gonna see if that actually changes
like if I make a bad move is it going to
say you just blundered you idiot okay
Queen G3
my uh the move that I was concerned most
about so White's really putting the
pressure on
uh
yeah I think I need to
get out of this pin as soon as possible
so let's do it
okay
my
12th
I could probably just punch the numbers
in but whatever
my 12th move is
King
h8
oh now you're being a little descriptive
here aren't you a good move preparing to
bring the Rook into the game
here's the updated board I'm preparing
to bring the Rook into the game with
King here
now that is really not my intention that
was more so just to get out of the PIN
I mean it does allow The Rook to have a
new move
but I'm really not so excited about
playing Rook to G8 okay
now I'll make my 13th move
hmm
Bishop G5 is illegal
okay this is where it's going to get a
little nutty
wait
a second
um
your
13th move is illegal
you have a
or let's say there there is a white Pawn
on F4
let's see what it says
oh I apologize for that mistake you're
absolutely right there is a white Pawn
on F4 so the move Bishop G5 is not legal
let me make a different move instead my
actual 13th move is Knight D5 attacking
your C6 pun
okay well Knight Knight D5 is a move but
it is not attacking my C6 Pawn
I hope that clears up any confusion
please let me know if you have any
questions or concerns
okay uh questions or concerns
um
I'll just go with Knight D5
yeah okay so it's saying Knight D5 now I
could win a pawn here
let me say
okay
my
my 13th move
is
what am I gonna play here
Queen is under Fire how do I want to
take
with the night or the bishop
I'm thinking I want to take with the
Knight
takes Knight is this some move yeah okay
so I'm thinking this this here
should be pretty cool I like my night
better than the bishop so
I like my the other way around I want to
keep this guy around so my 13th move is
going to be Knight takes night
Knight captures night
I should have said 13th move okay
you have captured my knight on D5 which
opens up your queen
and increases your control over the
center of the board here's the updated
board okay great
okay great oh maybe I should have put
Knight xd5 okay
note to self now I'll make my 14th move
F5 wow that's the move I was concerned
most about
Okay so
oh you've even given me some help you're
reminding me that you're attacking my
Bishop on E6 okay well you know the
board position don't you all right well
where's this guy gonna go I really do
have to come up with a move here
I'm gonna lose the piece back these guys
are both under Fire
um
my intention was to just hop in here
and maybe do something on the dark
squares
although
maybe I just fall back here
and after Pawn takes Bishop
then I could just recapture and I'm up a
pawn
I think I think I'm gonna go with that
yeah
there we go so night oh I have to be
even more specific here my
what move are we on my 14th move is
night
D5
hmm I'm gonna just do it like this
Knight D5 to
F6 okay this might get a little weird
and now let me just do a dash
or no night night five we'll understand
that Knight five
two F6
okay I think that'll work let's try it
a solid move protecting the bishop
and adding more control over the center
squares here's the updated board okay I
might need to correct it
let's see
F5 Knight F6 which is not entirely
correct okay it's going with f takes E6
let me just say
just to be clear
my last move was
me moving
my knight from D5 to
the
F6 Square
do you understand
I apologize for my mistake yes I
understand now that your 14th move was
Knight D to F6
that Knight five to F6 here's the
updated board
okay yeah but which Knight
now my 15th move would not be F takes E6
since your knight is actually an F6 not
on D5
as I previously thought instead I will
play Bishop G5 attacking you and forcing
it to move
I apologize for the confusion and thank
you for clarifying okay was I being a
sneak artist there
okay because this was a much better move
and then after a little dialogue I I um
I pulled it into making a terrible move
and Bishop G5 which is now only which is
now illegal
there isn't a pawn in the way okay
um I I tricked chat GPT
all right let's go with my I think I
might be having a little too much fun
with this chatbot all right we'll we'll
go with this bishop G5 move
why not
okay
my
uh what move around my 15th move is and
this is this is now winning for black
take on e4
Knight x e four
okay
an interesting move
sacrificing upon
to gain control over the side who are
you talking about
you sacrificed upon on purpose here's
the updated board
now I'll make my 16th move Queen H4
attacking your Bishop
Queen H4 attacking my Bishop
oh that's true
both my Bishops are Under Fire
tacking your bishop and threatening to
win a pawn
well
you could win this Pawn that cost the
queen all right so let's see if I could
uh
oh actually both of these
if you didn't point out you're attacking
my knight
hmm
okay I'm gonna take like this
boom
okay
my 16th
move is Bishop captures Bishop
all right a good move exchanging your
Bishop for my Queen's Bishop correct
in freeing up space for your other
pieces all right yeah I guess there's a
new square for my pieces at some stage
not right away no pieces could
immediately make use of E7
uh what's your 17th move my 17th move is
Queen takes E4
that is a good reply
okay so it is seeing the threat against
the coin there all right Queen takes E4
now my Bishop could react
and
probably just swiped the Knight earlier
I was saying that this is a bad piece
but at this stage I'm just up material
so let's be a trading machine
get all the pieces off
so my
17th move is
Bishop captures
night
a good move capturing might not and
forcing me to recapture with my Pawn
here's the updated board wonderful
okay
my only concern so far with the notation
is that still this move is not
completely clear
that Knight D to F6 because there were
two knights on the D file that could
have gone to D6
so
okay now my 18th move is a takes B3 okay
recapturing your Bishop with my pawn and
gaining control of the open a file
okay yeah open half open a file now for
team one
okay
uh what's a good move here I have
we have opposite color Bishops
probably put this Knight here and then I
could look forward to moving my
unopposed Center
yeah let's do that okay
my 18th
move is Knight F6 and this should clear
up the notation Maybe
this stage
I don't know let's see
Knight F6
is this really going to end smooth
there's something going to go really
Haywire
a good move developing your knight and
putting pressure on my Pawn on e4 oh
um that's not a Pawn on e4
maybe should I correct it
now my 19th move is Queen D3
now I'm not going to correct it it is at
least reacting
Queen D3
protecting the pawn on e4
and preparing to Castle okay yeah now
it's going little little bonkers a
little more bonkers
okay hang on let me let me give it a tip
just to be clear
there is currently no Pawn on e4
do you still I might be tricking it
again do you still want
your 19th move
to be
Queen D3 I'm trying maybe what's my plan
here am I trying to get it to play worse
moves
I apologize for my mistake thank you for
correcting me in that case I'll revise
my 19th move to Knight D5 oh what did I
just do
[Laughter]
oh man you don't even have a night
um
okay
we got 19 moves in okay I need to
correct it here so it's it's not just
gonna go smooth that's just how it is
um
I need
to correct you
you have no Knights on board
and my last move of Knight F6 is
attacking
your queen
on e4
do you want
to go with your
first idea of
19 Queen D3
now
okay
apologize for a mistake thank you for
correcting me since my night is not on
the board I can't play Knight D5 instead
I'll play Queen D3 protecting my prom
we're back in business all right
protecting my Pawn not quite protecting
the pawn but okay let's see we're gonna
go Queen T3 Queen D3 we're back
to a legal game of chess 19 moves
my turn
okay
let's push this guy
I wonder what happens once it I don't
know we're gonna find out all right my
okay
good move
my 19th move is
D5
a solid move striking at the center and
challenging my Pawn on e4 oh man the
imaginary E4 Pawn
here's the updated board
D5 your turn
hang on
hmm
it's whites
turn
it's your turn
what is your 20th move
all right it's getting much more
difficult now you are correct I
apologize for a mistake thank you for
pointing it out my for my 20th move I
will Castle kingside oh oh
man I'm trying I will Castle kingside
this will bring my king to safety and
connect my Rooks here's the updated
board
I think this is the end of the road
we got got 19 moves in I think we're
gonna have to call it right here uh it's
insisting on doing
some other stuff it's forgetting that
it's my move
it's not the right term forget but
castles I mean could I could I still
um let's see I'll still try come on
we've come this far
um
castling
let me be thorough
is uh
is in
illegal
move
you have already castled
you're absolutely right I apologize for
the confusion in that case for my 20th
move I will advance my H Pawn we're back
in business it's another legal move
H4 the idea of preparing a possible Pond
storm against your king in the future
here's the updated board okay
it's back on
all right my Bishop needs to do
something
and I could just take that pawn
should I say I could take that pawn you
sure you want to do that force him into
a
a worse move okay we're just gonna take
that pawn
okay
good move
my 20th 20th
move is
Bishop captures h
okay all right your 20th move Bishop X
H4 capturing my H Pawn this opens up a
discovered attack on my queen
not really
with your Bishop on H4 and Knight on F6
okay I do have a knight on F6
it's gonna spit out a next move it's
your turn again
no
it's not my
my turn
my last move
was 20.
my 20th move
Bishop takes H4
it's now your move
what is your 21st move
okay apologies again it is indeed my
turn thank you for correcting me for my
21st move I will play Queen H2 ooh
retreating my queen
to a safer Square also avoiding any
potential pins or discovered attacks by
your Bishop
pins are discovered attacks by the
bishop
okay yeah it's getting
messy Queen H2 got it correct it gotta
correct I want to try and get to uh
it's it's like it's pulling teeth now
we're pulling teeth okay
I'm sorry
but Queen H2 is an illegal
illegal move
your queen
is on D3
and
cannot move to H2
what is your 21st move
absolutely right apologize thank you for
getting my actual 21st move
I'll play Queen D2 okay which protects
the pawn on D4
no Pawn on D4 but okay it keeps an eye
on the bishop on H4
really okay not quite but that is a
legal move okay back in business
good move gotta give it some
encouragement all right so what do I
want to play here oh we're gonna hop in
the center
try and do some dangerous stuff
what's gonna happen when they're in
check is it going to recognize it's in
check
okay let's go with Knight E4
a monster in the center
my 21st move is
Knight E4
should I give it a hint attacking your
queen now let's just leave it like that
United whoa
it already knows your Knight's attacking
my queen and my Bishop
and my Bishop on G5 okay you're half
right
I am attacking the queen
it's my turn now I'll play Bishop F3
attacking your knight on e4
and also clearing the way for my queen
to move if necessary that's true there's
a new square for your queen but your
queen is a gunner
oh man
okay Bishop F3
that
was a terrible move
my
20 second move is Knight captures Queen
exclaim
let's do it
you're right that was a mistake on my
part I didn't see the night Fork
on my Queen Bishop after your 22nd 20
second move board looks like
well get some moves in here what move
are we at
I mean nearly a couple dozen
you have captured my queen and I have no
immediate way to recapture well done
it's your turn to make your 23rd move
ah
correction
my
last move now let's let's say it like
this
it's
actually your turn now
my last move was 22.
Knight captures Queen
what is your 23rd
move
you're right my apologies it's my turn
now after your 20 second move
the board looks like
okay
get in there
for my 23rd move I will play Rook a to
D1 putting pressure on your knight on G5
okay and potentially opening up a file
for my Rook to use later in the game
okay
so I mean this is not correct
um I need to correct it I think
so
the
notation for
blacks 20 second move
should be Knight captures Queen
Knight X
the notation Knight X G5
now how do I want to say it
your
Queen was captured on the D2 Square
do you understand
you're correct I apologize for the
mistake notation for your move should be
Knight takes Queen
thank you for correcting me oh man this
might be the end
okay I'm still gonna try I'm gonna go
with that Rook a to D1 move
okay
um
okay let's put it on
okay
my reply my
23rd move we'll just say
my 23rd move is
Knight captures Bishop
just to clarify which Bishop are you
taking with your knight there are two
Bishops on the board one on C4 and one
on F three
okay
hang on
you only had
one Bishop on the board
and that Bishop was just captured
on F3
you're right I apologize for the mistake
your 23rd move night capes is legal and
you have captured white White's Bishop
on F3 it is now White's turn
okay
it's your turn now
what is
your
24th move
it's legal you don't want to take my
knight that's cool okay how could I end
this really fast how about I take a pawn
and try and give mate we might be nearby
okay
my 24th move is Queen captures C two
who might be at the end
I'm looking for a mating too good move
capturing on Pawn on C2 now it's White's
turn what is your 25th move we can't
just skip turns okay
it's whites
turn now
what is your
25th move
is that where we're at now
I'm losing track here
okay
punch it in
as white my 24th move is Knight C4
attacking your queen on C2
okay there's no Knight on board
there is no night on
there is no
White Knight
on the board now
what is your 25th move going to be
here we go
as white my 25th move is actually D5
attacking your queen on C2
okay we really need to get to the end
here I'm one move away from giving mate
I am going to correct it until it would
get made on board
Okay so
you
let's see
D5 is not a legal move
not a legal move
what is
your 25th move going to be
I am a machine and sometimes make errors
as for my 25th move I will play Bishop
E3 attacking your queen on C5 oh man
I'm gonna have to give it a little help
here
okay Bishop E3 is also
illegal
you do have
a rook on D1 that you can move
now let's do it like this you do have a
pawn
on B3 that you can move
do you want to play
this is bad okay you want to play B4 so
I could mate you on my next turn
I won't say that part
where we're close to almost having a
uh a legal game right at the end it got
a little weird and there might be some
more weird stuff but let's see what it
has to say about this Checkmate position
okay I'm just gonna have to fill it in
that it lost her you know let's just go
with this
um if it comes back and says wow that
was a great Checkmate well done all
right let's see
uh first let's say
good move
um good Mo good move
my
25th
move
is Queen H2
now let's just leave it like that see
what happens
putting pressure on the F2 Pawn
it's now White's turn what is your 26th
move okay
actually
Queen H2
delivered
I can't even write Queen H2 is now
checkmate
well done congratulations on your
Victory it was a pleasure playing this
game with you
okay I think we're just gonna call here
we almost
the majority of the game was legal right
at the very end it was
a tough tough sled in there but uh let's
just say
okay
thank you
for playing
sort of
well
GG
see what we get
you're welcome was a pleasure playing
hope you learned a lot from this game
I certainly did okay well obviously this
was just for fun
uh Feel Free as usual to leave any
feedback to this video in the comments
section below this is a really
interesting uh chatbot there's really a
lot that uh you could do with it and I
figured
Let's uh have a little fun playing a
game of chess or at least trying to for
this video
anyhow feel free to leave a comment and
I hope you had a little fun watching
that's all for now take care bye
foreign